what are the component parts of somebody
who does that they have to read and they
have to be able to
type yeah and so
what they do is we our guys train on
typing speed every morning because i can
increase their throughput typically by
double so if i can get you to do twice
so many chat today you can sell twice as
many people per day right yep and so we
train on typing and the nice thing is
there's tons of really established wells
or software oh yeah tons and they're
free um but the one that we have is
super cheap i see their logs i can see
their speed improved i can see what time
they're logging all that stuff yeah and
then on flip side is reading
comprehension and there's tons of
programs online to help people read and
comprehend information faster anybody
who can read and type faster is a more
valuable human yes
fundamentally totally right and to the
same degree if somebody can listen and
detect language patterns and tonality
shifts will be a more persuasive
individual to help them in their life
overall if you enjoy these quick tips
and tricks there are way deeper
trainings that i have available on my
youtube channel you can go and check it
out see there